Inside Japan's corporations, the culture emphasizes the success of a company as a whole...
...to be more important than any single individual,...
...which might explain why one study found that 63 percent of Japanese felt guilty for taking paid leave.
But perhaps more concerning is this:...
...Long work hours don't necessarily mean high productivity.
In fact, Japan has the lowest productivity amongst the G7 nations.
Earlier, I mentioned the term "karoshi"; it means death by overwork.
It's legally recognized by the government...
...and usually is marked by a heart attack, stroke or suicide due to stress.
There's hundreds of cases of karoshi reported annually,...
...although some argue these cases are underreported...
...and that the real number could exceed that by up to ten times.